following seven counties dixie levy
citrus hernando hillsborough pasco
and pinellas and there are tropical
storm warnings in place
for 28 other counties there's a tornado
watch for south florida until 11 p.m
tonight and additional watches for
northeast and central florida are
possible
late tonight or wednesday morning
there's a moderate flash flood risk for
florida's west coast
until wednesday morning with flood
watches also in effect
i've amended my emergency order
to include baker bradford clay duval
nassau putnam and union counties and
that's reflecting the path of the storm
all models agree it's going to ride the
west coast of florida
then it's going to bear northeast into
the peninsula and likely go through
northeast florida
so the total counties under state of
emergency are now
at 33. the state eoc here has moved to a
level one so that's 24-hour
operations and we did that partially
because
the impacts to some of the more rural
fiscally constrained counties
we've been in contact with all those
counties let them know we want to be
here to supplement and support
as need be there are about 1500
customers across florida experiencing
power outages
but we've got between all the various
utilities
more than 7 000 restoration personnel
prepared
to respond to these outages in the event
that counties need to provide food and
water to residents we've prepared
supplies for points of distribution
including forklifts traffic cones tents
and other necessary items
we staged 24 generator units 24 water
pumps 5 hvac units
and 64 pieces of equipment such as for
forklifts and pellet jacks
use the logistical staging areas it's
important for floridians to have weather
alerts turned on
on your phone uh in your home as you
continue to monitor conditions in the
area this is going to end up
impacting the tampa bay area late
tonight
you're going to see impacts all across
the west coast
up the west coast into the morning hours
we're anticipating a landfall
probably between 8 a.m and 9 00 a.m
tomorrow
somewhere again on the nature coast or
big bend part of florida
please heed uh any type of warnings from
your local officials
there have not been any widespread
evacuation orders
there have been some voluntary orders in
a handful of counties and that's mostly
targeted at people who have special
needs who are power dependent
or who are in very low lying areas
but if you are provided that even on a
voluntary basis we ask that you please
take it seriously
and i cautioned uh earlier today just be
careful as you can
complete your storm preparations we'll
closely monitor this storm and provide
additional updates the roads will be
dangerous as this storm passes through
and in some ways it's fortunate this is
going to be in the in the wee hours of
the night there probably won't be a lot
of traffic on the roads
in places like the tampa bay area and in
the nature coast
uh midnight 2 a.m 3 a.m
but this is not a time to joy ride you
do have
hazardous conditions out there and then
if you do have a power outage
please if you do use a generator
understand you cannot allow the exhaust
to be inside your home inside your
garage
and if you set it up right outside a
window and have the window
open you can still get the exhaust to
come into the house that will
lead to carbon monoxide people we see
fatalities
we've seen in the last four years in
florida as a result of that so please
if you are experiencing a powder out and
you're going to use a generator
make sure that that exhaust is
exhausting away from your home
and is not being done inside the
structure
we'll continue to have updates we don't
anticipate major changes
to the track at this point but if there
is obviously
we will getting those from the national
hurricane center and we'll be passing
along that accordingly i'm going to let
kevin guthrie
our emergency management director come
up and say a few things
thank you governor thank you for your
leadership in this response
as you've heard the governor detail in
great detail
the preparations of the men and women
behind me of the state emergency
response team
they are prepared for this disaster and
they work 24 7 to ensure that we're
ready for it
again you heard quite a few details from
the governor
on the actual capabilities the state
logistical resource center is also
working 24 hours a day seven days a week
with approximately 50 national guardsmen
to help us there
um and the last thing that i would say
is
since we have very few power outages now
i would remind people if they wake up in
the morning and they start to have
damage
they see damage the best thing that you
can do as a homeowner
is to go out and photograph that damage
make sure you take pictures before you
start cleaning up
especially if you have any type of
flooding flooding only lasts
temporary so it's it's very important to
get those high water marks flood marks
on your homes
and then take those pictures very very
quickly with that being said
again as the governor said we will
provide additional updates as we have
them thank you
some questions for kevin or for me
governor um
you requested a uh emergency declaration
from the the president
before land falling i know i guess we
might get it
do you anticipate getting it and if we
don't get it it's gonna
prove yeah it's been approved yep yep
other federal assistance do you need
from the administration
they've been great i mean they acted on
that very quickly and so
um so we appreciate obviously we've uh
we've worked in working closely with
surfside
and that tragedy and so uh we we
appreciate we also think i know our
senators when i requested it
they were very quick to to urge that it
would be um
that will be approved so so i thank
senator rubio and senator scott as well
on the the search and rescue stuff i
mean obviously there
i think everybody was you know in the on
on the surf side have
any of those personnel in stage no we
have search and rescue that are ready to
go
and and i want to thank i've had an
opportunity over the last few days
to be able to visit with a lot of urban
search and rescue
from other states who came down
obviously team one and two
are down in south florida they were
there from the beginning 24 7. they
worked their hearts out
we brought all the rest of the search
and rescue teams from florida down there
they were working on that pile but we
also understood that
we just needed to make sure that we had
the preparations done
and so so kevin's got those teams that
are ready to respond
we have in surf side now ohio
new jersey virginia indiana
and so we really appreciate it i've had
a chance to go meet with some of those
folks
i want to thank royal caribbean for
housing them on one of those nice cruise
ships they're feeding them
and everything and so there's a lot of
good morale those folks
coming down we really appreciate it and
you know i told them i said
something tells me that um some of you
guys and firefighters
you just may retire to florida so we'll
probably see them at some point in the
future we'll have an update more
tomorrow
you